une décision que j'ai mûrement réfléchie
certains pourraient même reproché
d'avoir trop attendu
je suis celui qui prend le temps de la
réflexion de l'analyse avant de prendre
une décision
j'ai pris ce temps j'ai pris cette
décision j'aurai l'occasion de
l'expliquer que l'engouement dans les
semaines à venir voir dans les jours à
venir une c'est une décision qui est
irrévocable et je ne suis pas seul dans
cette démarche
j'ai décidé de crier avec d'autres un
nouveau parti politique en martinique un
parti politique qui reposerait sur des
bases idéologiques du patriotisme de la
responsabilité martiniquaise de la
dignité martiniquaise de la
reconnaissance d'un peuple martiniquais
avec des insignes martiniquais
représentatif des savoie ou
représentatifs de ce peuple martiniquais
mais un parti ouvert notamment au
développement économique à une forme de
réconciliation avec le monde de
l'entreprise
porteur d'un projet indique de
développement économique pour la
martinique
un parti novateur avec des méthodes qui
ne sont pas celles de la dictature mais
celle de la démocratie la profonde
démocratie un parti je tiens à préciser
qu'ils ne considèrent pas qu'il ya un
homme providentiel dans le pays mais que
c'est un sanguin de quoi faire les
choses